So let's look at another feature that is needed
to build scalable applications, task queues. So why do
we need task queues? Well at this time this
picture should be no surprise to you. Our dear
users accessing our application from various devices. And our
application for turning the response. Technically this response must
be returned within 60 seconds from the request. But
that's a long time. We've talked about the importance
about returning a response as quickly as possible to
our dear users. And we don't want them to
wait, even for seconds, right? And certainly not 60
seconds. You want to deliver that response as quickly as
possible. But let's say that the user activity triggers
something big to happen. For example, the user adds a
new conference and as a consequence of that 10,000
emails should be sent out to notify other users about
this conference. First of all, that's not possible within
60 seconds. And secondly, you certainly don't want the
poor user that just registered the conference to wait
for this to happen. Remember, the screen update depends on
your response so even seconds are crucial to keep
your application responsive. Come to the rescue are task
queues. This is exactly the problem task queues solve.
And it may not be emails triggering the need for
this, it could be something else. For example, an
image needs to be analyzed or a video needs to
be re-encoded. Many things that are not needed to
complete the request for the user, could use task queues